nevada has one of the lowest rankings in
the country when it comes to our number
of doctors
but now the valley does have three
medical schools and a promising supply
of physicians
so we're making progress but there's
still one issue holding us back
dr taylor vickery hooded by preceptor
dr travis snyder this spring hundreds of
medical students from across southern
nevada
walked the stage to become doctors
the key now is getting them to do their
graduate work here
according to the centers for disease
control and prevention states have on
average
272 doctors per 100 000 residents
but in nevada that number falls to just
198.
i think when you look at the number of
physicians per capita
we rank about 48. putting us near the
bottom and making it tough to find a
physician
dr mark khan is dean of the kirk
recording school of medicine at unlb
nevada's kind of been a victim of its
own success as it's
become a more popular place to live
it's grown but the health care sector
hasn't grown proportionately
for years nevadans have complained of
how tough it is to find a doctor
see a specialist and endless hours in a
waiting room
every doctor counts because it's very
difficult to recruit physicians
khan and gilear the dean at toro
university agree
these newly minted doctors are an
important first step
but the next one might be even more
important dr
jennifer onaga out of the 2021
class roughly a third will do their
graduate work here in nevada
through a residency or fellowship that
number
is critical to climbing out of a
decades-long doctor shortage
the numbers spare out that over 75
of residents wherever they trained stay
in the area i already had like roots
here have been part of the community
since high school
being from nevada originally and
having the opportunity to come to las
vegas
was really unique both dr guetta and dr
mcclintock graduated this month
and have local residencies already lined
up trouble is
not all specialties are offered here
urology
neurosurgery dermatology
radiation oncology medical oncology
forcing some physicians to leave if you
have students who would like to get to
residency in
town and therefore they stay more we can
really improve the
the the doctor shortage the city of las
vegas is expanding its medical district
and construction of the fully accredited
unlv school of medicine
is well underway but it's a long road to
solving
our shortage there are great doctors out
here there's good medicine being
practiced it's just
there's only so many of them
so what are your options if you can't
get in to see a doctor or specialist
more people are turning to concierge
medicine full access to your doctor you
get their mobile number
sounds expensive right well it might not
be as pricey as you think plus most of
them do take health insurance
so we'll dig into that coming up tonight
at 11 o'clock